over at fox business they say global
inflation hits highest level since 2008
oecd says inflation rose by the fastest
pace in 12
years and uh we all know what happened
in 2008.
that was fun i mean i wasn't uh i was i
was broke
you know back then so uh it didn't it
didn't impact me all that much
do you guys remember like the market
crash ian did right yeah it didn't
affect me at all i was working paycheck
to paycheck so it didn't mess with me
much
renting at the time yeah i was like 14
so it didn't affect me all that much
either no it wasn't wasn't as huge of a
deal affected people i knew
i mean it affected people some people i
knew really horribly unfortunately their
families
ended up on really rough times because
of that i remember when it happened
i told people was like everyone's
freaking out people i knew and i'm like
listen listen like here's the bottom
right i'm like right here and you're
here and the market crashes and i'm like
i don't know
yep i don't know you know what i mean
like san francisco more equal to
everyone and that's how socialism works
that's right the very very bottom we
went around because
everybody was cheering when it happened
i i don't remember any
even until like 2011. do you guys
remember like the fallout didn't seem to
start to
to rumble until like 2010 or 2011 what
do you mean like the
it just became a big deal like the fact
that we bailed out all these banks oh
okay
established all this debt didn't seem to
like shock people until a couple years
later yeah it was this weird thing
you started to see these populist
movements spring up on the right and
left you had occupy wall street and you
also had the tea party and the
establishment was clearly very
threatened by them i remember there was
this show
the newsroom which was always putting
forward the the pc
narrative in their stories and they had
an arc where the character was like
horribly intimidated by the tea party he
was a brave journalist for criticizing
them as if like no one on tv was doing
that it was hilarious how
how horribly um they were and how hard
they were trying to
make the tea party these villains i
remember that
it was heroic they still do that today
they're like oh this person holds
this brave courageous revenant idea
that trump is bad yeah that's really
revolutionary that i'm really impressed
as an aside for those that are listening
we're experiencing internet troubles yes
so i just switched to one of our backups
because i guess like internet across the
board for our network is being hit
really hard it was a bit bad storm so i
switched
hopefully this one works it'll probably
reduce the resolution but we're gonna
need to get a power cable to charge
because
it's just going through my phone okay
okay yep hopefully that works what do
you have usb-c
yeah yeah right here here yeah is it
long enough yeah i think so
there you go let's go so that means
fewer people are going to see this so we
can talk about
more controversial things or or our
feelings let's just start
our deeper feelings let's talk about
legalizing hemp because if the if the
wood industry if the lumber industry
really is going spying
interesting well let's let's show this
check this out you want to talk about
market crash we got this
this tweets going viral from brian
nichols says fyi
and there's a big pile says fall 2020 1
000 in lumber
and you can see all of this wood and
they've painted the ends of them blue
and then next to it says may 2021 one
thousand dollars in lumber
dude that's nuts uh for those that are
listening it's basically like
a tenth that's crazy
quarter i haven't been able to bat fact
check this at all but i've heard that it
was had something to do with trump's
um tariffs so that the canadian lumber
won't they won't ship it down here
because it's too expensive i don't
believe it that's interesting yeah i
couldn't find anything i don't believe
it
so we had um uh when we had joe canton
he was talking about pacific northwest
and timbering and all that
and us regulations making it very
difficult to you know
source wood in the united states i i i
just don't believe it i don't trust the
media
when whenever they come out and they're
like you know donald trump did this it's
bad i'm like i don't believe you that's
like what wouldn't they blame him for
yeah it's the boy who cried wolf i'm
sure some of this is his fault right but
like
when you label everything as being the
result of trump's failures and it's like
we're not gonna
believe you right he actually is brian
stelter could be sitting in a room with
don lemon and he could fart and then
look at him it was donald trump
and don lemon goes i saw him he was
right
it was it was it absolutely was yeah it
takes
first of all if i farted it would be
much louder it would be the greatest
fart you ever heard
yes so lumber this means houses are
going to spike
yeah it means paper so it's good at 19
000 to the average cost of a house right
now it's gonna have a major ripple
effect check this out
so hold on a minute right we got food
shortages already we got beef and
chicken and a lot of people keep saying
like whenever we talk about this they're
like tim there's no shortage i'm like
okay well we ain't getting it
there's reports as a trucker shortage
and people are like there's not there's
sugars all over the place i'm like okay
well they're not people some for some
reason people aren't driving yeah
gas shortages food whatever chlorine i
don't know weird stuff yeah that's kind
of weird so think about it this way
somebody's got to do a job there's a lot
of jobs that require wood that's why
people go buy wood all the time
so i was talking to these these guys
that i know they build skateparks and i
asked them about like hey what's going
on like what have you seen and they
basically told me it's really bad right
now and so here's what i'm worried about
these guys are gonna go to their clients
and be like hey you know normally we do
these these events and it costs a
hundred thousand dollars to build the
park
okay well now it's gonna cost five
hundred thousand dollars to build the
park and the event is gonna be like no
that's literally our entire budget
we still gotta hire label labor we gotta
rent space we can't do it
we'd have to charge 200 per ticket
instead of you know twenty dollars
or or forty dollars so they say okay
we're not doing it
events get cancelled this exacerbates
the labor shortage
it means that without the raw materials
to do the work there's a ripple effect
it's not just the wood that you can't
buy it's the it's it's the construction
jobs
it's the jobs that those job that money
goes and circulates to so sandwich shops
yeah it's it's the events that we're
going to hire the contractors to build
the thing for them in the first place
that now can't do it
think about like like shows like stages
like broadway or something we got to
build a set sorry we can't get the wood
no
no show and then people don't work and
then no money there's already a labor
short which is why it's crazy to me that
they're talking about how it was like
we're in a v-shaped recovery
here let me let me pull this up we got
the story this is what a recovery looks
like
the v-shaped recovery is here and i'm
like it's it's worse than it's ever been
what are you talking about man
uh so we mana internet went out again
so this must be a regional outage
because my phone you know should not be
cutting out like that
but uh not this is brutal
well you live in the middle of nowhere
welcome back everyone
yeah to the hottest of the hot that's
all right awesome that's gonna try
satellite show
we're just gonna we're going to our
third internet option right now backing
up a satellite
maybe we'll get a little bit more of a
fluid uh vibration that way
we love you please stay tuned what this
is
is telling me is that we desperately
need a materials revolution like
wood isn't graphing we need a graphene
revolution tim if
that's what you think then then i'm with
you man i agree that for real
or or just figure out how to like you
know you can recover plastic
and then um break it down with mushrooms
like a pestylopsis microsporon turn it
into sugar
interesting i don't know please educate
me on this i don't know anything about
it you can use that sugar and alloy with
other materials to create like building
materials
wow recovered plastic digestive and
recovered plastic
so why do you think this isn't being
done right now because the
copper industry has a huge monopoly on
the system right now and obviously the
the lumber
industry you can see william randolph
hearst amongst others you know tree
magnets
they they want to they don't want hemp
to be legal randall hurst actually tried
to get people to make it illegal because
it was competing with his
back in the 20s and 30s uh and then what
other materials
are are up for obviously the petroleum
industry the steel industry which is
like the coal industry
dude it all ripples and so they keep
saying it's like oh supply just needs to
catch up it's like bro nobody wants to
work
exactly no but nobody's working and here
i i just got i i got a bunch of these
stories but look at this one pbs
are unemployment benefits keeping
americans home
oh look at the labor shortage and it's
from yesterday does just paying
people not to do something stop them
from doing it this is the problem with
leftist media is that
the right was talking about this months
ago yeah
last year thomas massey and some
republicans were like hey don't pay
people not to work
it was a bad idea yeah now pbs is like
that's that's how you destroy your
economy
it's incredible yeah the entire
unemployment industry is based on like
here we'll pay you
is if but if you start working again
we're going to cut off your benefits
yeah exactly it's horrible what the heck
right so when you're getting 16 bucks an
hour
what what are they going to pay this is
you know what's creepy we were trying to
uh we were trying to order food here the
other day
and a bunch of the restaurants were just
closed for no reason oh yep i'm like
i'm pretty sure wednesday is at memorial
day you know what i mean like one more
day was monday
tuesday they were closed wednesday
they're closed and i'm like did people
just not show up
yep so we so it was funny because we
ordered food and then it defaulted for
today
because for no reason the restaurant was
closed the other day and i guess
you know no one noticed and so when you
clicked order it just defaulted for the
next availability
that's annoying yeah yeah yeah yeah the
food arrived today yeah we had it was
delicious
that works out yeah shut up and i'm like
okay so i guess they reopened i was
worried that they were going to be like
permanently closed or something
maybe it's just people wanted a longer
long weekend you know it definitely
would probably coincide with not having
a lot of customers too
i would think because most businesses
wouldn't shut her for three days for
memorial day unless they were
not dude i can't have employees though i
mean if people aren't showing up
you kind of have a choice yeah you drive
around looking at these restaurants and
they're just like
offering crazy amounts of money oh yeah
the waffle house had a sign that's like
we are fighting the pancake patriarchy
please apply here and no we'll promote
women more i'm not kidding yeah we'll
promote women
you said pancake patriots yes the
pancake patriarchy i was like you know
what i'm not eating here is ridiculous
yeah that's creepy but they they were
trying to push uh social justice
yeah yeah it was like using social
justice stuff but to try to get people
to work there was very strange
yeah because of people with college
degrees or the people who are going to
be working
true wow my goodness you're right
posting them man wow that's brutal
that that's mean to the waffle house
people yeah honestly no
in all honesty yes like the people at
waffle house like work pretty hard yeah
you know that's
true yeah that's what i'm saying like i
i think
most uh college students in the liberal
arts field or not
yeah wouldn't like survive at a job
seriously absolutely well you got to pay
your back your loans you know
that's true and if your love of theater
is strong enough you gotta
do it somehow i've been there so what do
we do uh we got this story from
from uh business insider warren
buffett's favorite market indicator hits
200
signaling stocks are overpriced and a
crash may be coming well that's almost
like they just flooded the market with
liquidity without really thinking about
the long-term effects it does seem like
that yeah i mean
i wonder if they were thinking about the
long-term effects do you look at the
things that have been hit beef and gas
yeah i don't know lies i really think
they just look for these band-aids to
slap
onto things and they hope they'll be
able to figure something out later
i don't think it's intentional i don't
think they're trying to destroy it i
think they're just unbelievably
short-sighted
makes sense yeah i'll say the other day
that it's like the solution is crazy is
exacerbating the problem
they don't they don't know what to do so
they're like the economy's on is in
flames and it's collapsing so just pump
more money and print more money like
crazy exactly
that's what most these countries do when
before hyper hyperinflation hits yes the
economy starts stagnating so they print
money and spend it
they do these big government spending
packages where they're like i know
if we print a bunch of money and then
spend it ourselves that will kick-start
the economy because then the people we
hire will buy stuff
and then you end up with trillion dollar
bills yeah modern monetary policy they
did that after world war ii
they they invested in the infrastructure
though were able to rebuild like
factories and things that were
actually did kickstart the economy
seemingly but they didn't do that this
time around they just gave the money out
did you guys hear that russia dumped uh
like 45 billion us dollars from one of
their funds
russia's right they don't want to i mean
it's not like it's the most
amount of money in the world or whatever
but that's 45 billion yeah they're
selling off
so if russia is trying to get off the
dollar and china's trying to get the
dollar and
then china's using dollars for the belt
and road initiative i think
uh maybe buy some maybe you guys should
try to get out of the dollar too
that's awesome i'm not giving financial
advice here all right i'm not qualified
but american citizens i personally think
it might be a good idea to try to
diversify your portfolio a little bit if
you have savings maybe you should have
something out what if they don't have a
portfolio or savings
yeah that's the other thing yeah exactly
that's that's a very serious problem but
i guess my point is if you have money
saved up it's probably
i mean i shouldn't say probably there's
a chance it will not be quite as
valuable down the line
and that might might be more so the case
than it usually is i mean yeah and we
could see that
i mean maybe halfing in value i don't
know but
i i don't have a lot of faith in the
dollar
no dude if you're if so i i'm talking to
the skatepark guys
if i was trying to get any of the work
done today four to five times the cost
yeah impossible we'll be able to do it
yeah
we would not be able to get any of that
job done yeah so
all the stuff we have right now this is
what you got to realize everybody if you
watch like the cass castle vlog
we got like the venue we're putting
together we're gonna be doing these live
events it would be impossible
if we didn't already do it last year
think about what that means
the economy has taken a hit that bad i
am telling you right now last year we
hired a company that came and built
stuff
we're gonna use that stuff so that we
can do shows and expand the business
it would be impossible for us to do it
today we got to get creative with
materials i'm thinking for construction
because
i had plans to like go build wood stuff
but i don't think i think we got to
either get shipping containers
or i'm open to other ideas like geodesic
don't
style stuff maybe not i don't know what
steel plastic is like steel and
plastic cheaper probably i don't know
man probably but it's not i don't know
abs we'll 3d print everything
dude we could piece by piece we can 3d
print the joints and the tubes to make
like giant
domes out of dude this is brutal man our
internet is fried
there's nothing we can do the youtube
show is suffering as a result can you
what's up guys on youtube
let's go to super chat i see lots of f's
i'm sorry
yeah i'm having fun with you guys you
know
i would just be hanging out with you
guys tonight anyway
we have satellite the satellites down
too dang that's rough so we should
are you going back to the flip back to
the the fastest internet and just
i'm trying just hope it works i mean
what a recipe for disaster we have here
not just in terms of your internet but
in terms of the economy overall
i mean with the dollar what yeah
inflation being as high as it's been
since
2008 the stock market being drastically
overvalued at least according to warren
buffett's indicator i mean usually what
happens is
when things uh go downhill when you have
a recession
they try to put a bunch more money out
into the economy they try to increase
liquidity to get people investing i
don't know
like what do they expect to be able to
do this time when it crashes
it seems like a great reset yeah
yeah like a problem with our system of
government and it might not just be our
system
democracy in four-year terms for
presidents but these people come into
office with like a four-year
vision they don't have like a long-term
goal because if they try and start
a 20-year plan right now in eight years
they're gone exactly
this kind of a system incentivizes
short-term thinking from political
leaders but
having a dictator that's like for life
would be
obviously bad yeah well no but this is
the thing right we are taught in schools
from day one like democracy equals good
monarchy equals bad so we never really
think about the downsides of democracy
or some of the potential positives that
came along with monarchy and one of the
positives that came along with monarchy
was that the king had to really think
about the long-term health of his
kingdom because he was going to be
leaving it to his children so if they
accumulated a lot of debt
that would be very bad for his lineage
but in our current system the only
way a politician can actually make money
is if they do everything they can to
pull wealth out of the system during
their short term
and leave the people with less overall
and this actually incentivized our
leaders to want to have
children like literally establishing a
new church so you could marry different
women so you could get a son
right like that's insanity but to be
fair
but they really wanted to have kids now
almost none of them too angela merkel
doesn't have any
macron doesn't have any a lot of these
leaders just have
they don't really care about the future
because they don't really care about
their kids
exactly there was that quote from john
maynard keynes when they asked him
what a perfect person to bring up right
now right they asked him well what do we
do when we accumulate too much debt and
he said well in the long run we'll all
be dead
of course john maynard keynes never had
any children so of course he had that
attitude
but it's funny you can really tell how
optimistic
or pessimistic a person is based not on
whether they say they're optimistic or
pessimistic but on whether they tell you
they want to have children and people
who want to have children usually more
optimistic about the future
and the people who say no i can't bring
kids into this world well they're almost
always pessimists it's funny i remember
my dad kind of running this experience
experiment we were at a bar together
right after i graduated college and
he was asking uh people around my age
are you up an optimist or a pessimist oh
i'm an optimist blah blah blah
are you gonna have kids i don't know if
i could bring my kids into this world
it's like okay well then you're a
pessimist yeah and it's just interesting
like you said all these foreign leaders
don't have children or if they do they
have a very small family i think it's
because they don't have a whole lot of
faith in the future
does putin have a family i think he does
yeah yeah
he does yeah was there a video of like
him teaching his daughter to do like
yeah
how to interfere in elections you send
ballots to this
first you have non-state actors buy
forty six thousand dollars worth of
facebook ads
she's like she's a little kid and she
reaches over to press enter and she
looks at him and he like nods at her and
then
presses enter and that says like
facebook ad purchased one dollar and
he's like oh
no then you just see the electoral map
switch he's like yes
i'm so proud of you yes the towers
oh man look what the world is being
deprived of this comedy gold
because of the internet we got nothing
we're not live
no we're not evolving i'm gonna get
another water bottle do it
no one said you could leave [ __ ] i'm
kidding it's anarchy
oh man uh it's the apocalypse it really
does feel like it
they're out to get us with this internet
thing yeah
dude it's because sheamus is here it's
true he's grabbing candy
it's proved by the foot you know what
that's right it all started when he
started promoting that merch that's
that's t-shirt was that freedom tunes
merch
i was trying to tell people to get out
of the dollar tim send those worthless
dollars to me get some freedom tunes
murder i know i want to excite people to
diversify from the dollar
without panicking people about the
dollar i mean obviously the writing's on
the wall
but you know don't sit in one absolutely
i think you're right and you know
another thing i've been thinking lately
because i started hitting the gym more
lately oh yeah
um i think that you should invest in
yourself so that when it really hits the
fan
you're prepared what do you mean by
investing in yourself lydia hit the gym
get stronger eat right make yourself
i feel really targeted right now for a
snack
[Laughter]
i've been working out more lately every
everybody should be
super ripped wearing a red flannel and
carrying around
an accent chop down some trees that's
right and build a log cabin that's what
i'm saying are we talking about jack
murphy right now
no no everyone women men dogs
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you